your family has got to be very proud of
your success yeah man especially my
father my father is very proud of me I
know he's proud because every time I
called him up on the phone he's like Jay
Pharoah when he says his lease has a
really loud so I know people around him
I could just imagine him like when I'm
sitting when I'm on the phone with him I
can imagine being around a group of
people he's like Jay Pharoah and he puts
it down like he thought anything I'm
doing right now he calls me he asked me
do like impression sometimes he used to
call me up make me do Barack like he'd
call me up
and he'd be like yo I got Barack on the
phone everybody hey Barack and I'd be
like dad you don't know Barack Obama
okay you know me and you're lying to
your friends yeah they should know that
but I'm like okay let me do the
impression Mike well I don't know how
you got this number and pretty much you
can go screw so because I'm in Hawaii
sipping mai-tais and puffs and Jays
thank you
your dad's got to have impressions of
yours that are his favorite like the
ones that he demands that you do over
and over and even just to impress his
friend just the ones he likes yeah it's
like jay-z he'd always jazz me do that a
lot okay he does the phone call set off
hits me up and he's just like um he's
like yo jay-z I'm like yo how did you
even get this number
yo disconnected 444 you know I'm saying
dude living like that he's got his favor
everybody does man but you know I it's
whatever to me man I have fun I got I
have fun doing them so you know I think
they're cool yeah y'all think they're
cool
[Applause]
you